previously on Hotel Hell I found out the
upscale junip Hill Inn in Winds of
Vermont is bleeding
money so you're losing over $200,000 a
year we're in trouble and it's because
the owners have spent a fortune to make
this place look like an art museum I've
always thought that you should live with
nice things if you can afford them
treating it like their own private
Country
Club I quickly realized the rooms were
vacant because Robert and Ari have
alienated themselves from the town and
the in's appearance is completely
evening what is that smell smells [__]
it's like someone's shot under the bed
and instead of working with their
employees excuse me bragging about
excuse me excuse me excuse me I am the
boss this place is [__] they're
oppressing him like indentured servants
I'm barely surviving financially and
emotionally I'd be very careful about
coming down on me too hard and
communication is almost non-existent
unless you [__] ask how are you
supposed to [__] know well I have
been asking I said where does this
chicken so ask him again and what's
worse I was completely shocked to learn
that the staff never get paid on time
like pulling teeth to get my paycheck
you don't get paid it takes forever to
get my paycheck and when I do it's
usually something's left out and when I
confronted Robert and Ari in front of
everyone all I got was excuses I don't
have a secretary Gordon I'm sorry are
you always this pathetic they don't have
to work here how dare you go on then you
pump as [__] don't talk to me like that
you still haven't got it that this place
is
[Music]
sinking so far my stay at Vermont's
Juniper in has been shocking yeah but it
smells [__] and the root of the problem
is beginning to show you don't get paid
I've seen with my own eyes how poorly
this place is run but now I need to see
what happens to the bottom line when
Robert and Ari Ed Juniper Hill as their
own private playground and to T all
their friends I'm hoping estate manager
Ryan can help me lot of the staff are
telling me there um friends pop up from
Manhattan and come and spend weekends
and sit drink and be merry are these
guys actually
paying uh no Robert had a slew of
friends come and stay for free and eat
for free for weeks at a time and that's
why they've been losing money since I've
been here what do the colors mean help
me understand that green means they're
paid in full red means they have not
paid oh my God I have 50 room nights
that's between November and December
we'll see the average they're $2 $0000 a
night but that's it's like $10,000 in
Revenue that's
$10,000 they're running it almost like
at a clubhouse almost like they're
trying to buy friends and Robert Prides
himself as the superior business person
Robert walks around like he's going to
King and that everybody hears a bunch of
hicks this is insane and this is like a
private club for him he's worked with
the servers before and accepted a
portion of the tips oh my God [__]
hell he's taking their bloody tips this
guy is mad I can't believe this he
doesn't pay them and then he takes their
tips I got to talk to
him how are we Barbara how are you today
good I just out of interest is it true
that Robert takes a percentage of the
tips yes he does yeah what percentage of
tips does he take what would he get he
gets the same as you yeah it's really
hard to keep track of the tips I the the
bookkeeping it doesn't it seems
inconsistent why is he touching the tips
he did the same thing for New Year's
they felt that because they need to
cover part of the band that they took
the tips off tip
that's why we don't make anything here
an owner has no right to take the
staff's tips and with all the room and
food comps Robert is giving his friends
it's no wonder the Inn is
struggling the staff shouldn't be
subsidizing the Inn so Robert and his
friends get to live the high life for
free it's sickening I have to confront
him and figure out this
nonsense I just had a look around and I
just I am flabbergast I'm going to be
really Frank and I'm going to try stay
so calm but if I smell BS that you start
going into denial I'm going to let rip
again I studied your
reservations last November December 49
rooms were given out for free and on top
of that they ate they drank for nothing
I'm not even tipping and I'm just the
[__] are you doing tell me why I thought
I needed to have somebody here rather
than having two other guests in the
hotel all by themselves to have more
energy
you're making it worse not only do your
friends not leave tips but when people
do tip the staff you take a share on
nights that I work I did take tips that
is
disgusting why do you think you got a
right to that I have tried to work with
my staff to teach them that this is the
way I want service done you're so bad I
take a percentage of the tips based on
the amount of work that I do and who
does the books on those tips uh
Ari but if I'm doing their job and I
can't get across to them you're the
owner you're not the head bus boy you're
not the barman you're the [__] owner
what I was saying wasn't getting through
so the psychology was that if I started
to take tips they would maybe pay
attention to that that is insane it's
the worst management module I've ever
heard in my entire life do you honestly
need a 70-year-old lady's
[Music]
tips so 15 20 grand worth of
complimentary rooms in a food in a
2-month period I'm just doesn't make
sense I have to tell you that the reason
I did that was because I thought that
they would at least tip my staff but
they didn't tip your
staff sorry to piss on your bonfire well
then I will call my friends and I will
tell them look what happened you haven't
got the [__] balls to call your
friends and ask them to leave a tip yes
I do call them
then and asked them I thought at least
out of generosity you would have left a
couple hundred dollar tip for the team
hello Dana yes it's Robert you stayed
here recently and um I was under the
impression that you and Greg left a tip
did you leave a tip I left some money
with
you no no no but you said you were going
to send additional
tip I think my time's done here that was
one of the things that I was hoping you
had done um if I didn't do what I was
supposed to do I'm very sorry and I left
the money with you well wait a minute
there's others to call too Gordon oh
dear Gordon has left he thinks I'm
stealing my staff's tips
unbelievable joke hey Ray it's Robert
did you tip the staff cuz they're
telling people that they haven't been
tipped I left the money with you oh so I
need to do
that I I somehow lost that [__] idiot
Gordon left thinking I'm a liar
I feel as if I'm I'm at the end of my
rope I mean I'm going to lose everything
I'm going to have to start all over
again if this doesn't work
and I just don't seem that I can can do
it anymore I know I can't do
[Music]
it I just left Juniper Hill after
catching Robert in a lie about a staff
getting tips I was under the impression
that you and Greg left a tip did you
leave a tip I left for money with you
the guy is maddening and I don't know if
I've got it in me to help fix the place
I'm so pissed off with Robert right now
honestly I cannot stand any more of
these bloody lies this guy doesn't
deserve the team that is in his hotel he
treats everyone so badly when you're in
your [__] kitchen all day long and
you're on the internet instead of
actually trying to perfect the menu he
doesn't even pay them properly I had to
wait 5 weeks before I got a paycheck I
work very long days and I haven't been
paid in 3 weeks how can someone so rich
not pay the people he
employs that's something I simply won't
stand
for as angry as I am I feel I have to
help the staff get paid and I have an
idea of just how to do it I'm going to
hire a team of white Club movers to
assemble all of Robert's most valuable
antiques from the storage units the
basement and around the Inn I'm hoping
when confronted with all the money he's
wasted I can convince Robert to sell s
some of his vast collection to pay his
[Music]
staff if this is going to work I must
stay calm while I talk to Robert um I've
come back not for you but for the staff
they deserve
better we're losing on average $ 15 to
$220,000 a month and we are short but
you have a serious hobby of sort of an
art collector an art dealer I mean you
could open in a museum how many pieces
do you have in there oh my God hundreds
what are we talking about everything
collectively all those beautiful oil
paintings the expensive stuff at a
suitable
auction um maybe $300,000 $300,000 and
that would supplement you for the next
12 months 18 months yes that would
certainly get us through that would get
us through 2 years um right there's
something I want you to see I want you
to come with me please there's one thing
we need right now is an injection of
funds
wow Robert no man alive needs this much
stuff walking in it was shocking now
antiques oil paintings silverware does
it not I mean frustrate you that we're
sat with all this and yet we can't pay
our staff
properly there's someone I'd like you to
meet she's the head Auctioneer at bonom
in Boston Amy good morning good morning
Gordon nice to see you Gordon great to
see you likewise thank you so much for
coming um we're in the [__] basically
and this stuff needs to go we need to
raise as much money as possible so
what's the best price we can get for all
this
[Music]
stuff what you have here doesn't read as
a collection to me it's kind of an
accumulation a lot of copies of
things or if they are of the period that
they're supposed to be there's some
condition issues
[Music]
um I would
say about
25,000 say that again
25,000
$225,000 all this all this Amy's opinion
on our our things was shocking and I
can't really believe that on the
painting the painting is a copy and not
a good one I'm afraid how much is that
worth I can't imagine what someone would
pay for it it's it's really very low
value wow Robert I thought you said it
was expensive 18th century well it's
dated I dated 177 it is but it's not
actually of that period at all I'm
sorry did you know that was a copy I did
not know that that was a
copy lots of copies reproductions
reproductions we're hoping the ballp
part 3 to 400,000 25 grand for
everything yeah that won't even get us
through the next five weeks even all
this amazing silverware I put a $100 on
everything on this table $100 what about
this first period this Sheffield yeah
it's plate what about this 175 bucks
those are bar our candlesticks they just
don't bring very much at auction I'm
afraid is this the kind of collection
you'd be willing to sell at bottoms
would you take the whole lot no we
wouldn't wow we would have to say no
we're floating as if we've got this
asset full of3 or $400,000 worth of
antiques we haven't and we're distracted
with the bits of crap in here it was a
wake up call thank you that's the start
appreciate it thank you it means that we
don't have the backup that we thought we
had we paid more money for [__]
storage than they're worth than they're
worth does that not bring it home a
little bit earlier that you need to be
an inkeeper not a part-time anti dealer
because you fooled me you give me the
tour and I thought wow this guy is uh
he's got serious cash to burn but right
now we're even further in the [__] than
I thought we
were so the pressure intensifies y you
need to focus on fixing the business cuz
that's what's going to generate
sufficient funds to keep this place open
and I don't think you quite realize that
your
staff they're
miserable they don't like Aries barking
excuse me bragging about excuse me I am
the boss you bitching when you're in
your [__] kitchen all day long and
you're on the godamn internet instead of
actually trying to perfect the menu it's
not a nice atmosphere for the staff
currently and if they quit you're [__]
they are staff they're not pigs that
live in the [__]
basement if you think that's not the
case and you're that delusional and
you're not prepared to listen to
anything I'm saying you're [__] sell
the in sell this [__] in here and give
up
I've just come back to try and save
Juniper Hill in and I thought I could
use some of the owner's vast array of
antiques to get the cash flowing but
I've just discovered I would say about
25,000
$25,000 all this all this that I was
wrong that won't even get us through the
next 5
weeks with no assets the challenge to
make this place work is bigger than ever
tomorrow I have to start the process of
change before I get stuck in there's one
thing I want to
[Music]
try oh
God it's bloody
roasting [__] my feet are freezing
[Music]
now morning now it's time to see if I
can get through to Robert and Ari can I
just borrow you for two minutes I want
to show you something yeah both you
together I'd like you to come up to my
uh room thank you if this place is going
to work as a business Robert and Ari
need to hear some home truths about how
their paying customers really feel about
their precious in um ladies and
gentlemen good morning morning morning
thank you so much for uh popping into my
room how was your stay last night well
we didn't know where to go when we
walked in so we walked around and around
until we found somebody to help us check
in I was slightly disorientated when I
checked in as well I mean there's no
signs in in terms of reception from desk
or bar lounge or how are the rooms IED
space heers to hear the room up oh
really yeah three of them when I checked
the room it was like a SAA he sounds
aggravated raise your hands if you'd
come back
please like it is not like it is there's
someone I'd like to hear from who hasn't
said anything yet he is a lead inspector
of the Diamond collection of hotel and
ins Across
America in a nutshell very disappointed
didn't meet expectations from the moment
I walked in with no greeting no check-in
area I was totally lost and the bar is a
joke should not even be there folks it
looks as if it's set up for a wedding
the hospitality is nice but everything
else
fails how do you feel I don't want my
guests to have that experience you know
our goal is to please people that's why
we're in the in business and we've
obviously Fallen really short um for me
I think that's positive feedback so I'm
grateful entirely let me tell you thank
you all can I keep you two here please
thank you the guest feedback has
certainly been constructive thank you
and Robert's even using a word I've
never heard from him before we are sorry
but I'm shocked by AR's response to the
guest complaints what's the matter with
you why are you so angry with guests why
are you running an in when you're so
bitter you look like you don't give a
[__] I'm not saying that I don't like
the guest but if you have ever been an
inkeeper it's
24/7 no one is
more touched by what these people say
wow Ari is cing that's I would love this
to be our our private home but I am and
Ari does have a different way of dealing
with I see that based on my
experience I would seriously request
both you actually sit down and
reconsider whether you should be in this
business going
[Music]
forward it's clear to me that Ari isn't
cut out for the hospitality business and
even though Robert now understands how
he's let down his guest he needs to
understand that he's also let down his
staff and failed to recognize their
potential I've got a plan that will help
Robert to see what he's doing wrong and
how he can fix things in his
[Music]
kitchen I've asked Chef Julian to cook
three dishes from Robert's expensive old
menu and three new dishes of his very
own creation once he's finished we're
going to pretend I cook the new ones and
see what Robert says crucially Junior's
dishes are all ones that could be served
on a $29 menu half what Robert currently
charges look at that $74 $29 let's go
good luck okay
yes I can't wait to see what Robert
thinks of Julian's affordable food when
he thinks I've cooked it I asked him to
cook a three course meal yeah he cooked
his lamb this crab cake and the dessert
that's the $74 version I cook the other
meal I got hold of some chicken some
sprouts and I used the crab and a
butterscotch pudding with some
caramelized popcorn $29 that's what
those three cses going to cost you okay
juni's three new dishes are fantastic
and fairly priced that would go a long
way towards bringing guests back through
the front door now that Robert thinks
I've cooked them I bet Lov them talk to
me
excellent fabulous and the um Russell
Sprouts are really good too you've
actually Leaf them and it's very pretty
this is a much better
value I've never heard you use that word
value and we could get two for the price
of
one what we should do so so my menu or
Julian's menu your menu my menu I'm
flattered but there's something I need
to tell you I didn't make any of this
Julian cooked
everything I
felt at that very moment that I had done
Julian a disservice Robert have you got
something you'd like to say to your Chef
Julian I'm sorry that I haven't given
you the freedom to do what you need to
do I guess I have to eat it and say that
I have restricted him from being who he
can be which is is really difficult and
um I have to say that this is
delicious coming up he's emotionally
constipated Robert has a major decision
about his future with Ari I think he
gave
up now that owner Robert's heard from
the guest very disappointed didn't meet
expectations and sampled the kind of a
affordable high quality food his Chef
can cook when given the chance excellent
fabulous I didn't make any of this
Julian cooked
everything I hope this is all starting
to sink in with him well how you feeling
I'm feeling all sorts of things I mean
there's of course fear but surely hope
too your Chef's food was amazing
absolutely it was an epiphany I
feel regretful that I have come across
in the way I have and that I haven't
exhibited to my staff the leadership
they needed and the compassion that
apparently I'm I must be void of I think
for you to tell them how you're feeling
what you're going to commit to how
important they are for you I know that
this place wouldn't be here without them
and I'm wanting to do everything I can
to show them that we can make this
work I'm glad Robert's On A New Path I
just hope it's not too late for your
staff to learn to trust him again you
are all valuable to me and to Ari and to
Juniper Hill and I fear that we have not
always expressed that and we want to
show you that we are going to make a
difference sorry for your paychecks
being
late sorry for taking part of the
tips sorry for not Comm
communicating because that was the
reality and one that I'm not proud of
that we're not proud of but one that we
certainly Inc correct and that's what we
want to do the business is short of cash
flow I thought there was a substantial
collection of 3 to
400,000 worth of assets I mean why don't
you explain exactly and the things that
were assembled here um they said lucky
if we got
25,000
we are on our ass it is going to be
difficult and I think Robert has
realized the bubbles
burst and he understands the truth to
where we are I think there's a
perception that we are these wealthy
magnets coming in and Lord of the manner
sort of things that's not who we
are you know I knew there was some um
bad situations here but I stayed because
I want to be here and I want to help him
and I believe what he says and I'm very
proud of you Robert you're the man that
I've always known and loved it's he's
coming back I'm glad to see that you
know we're facing facts and uh that's
the only way we're going to get out of
this agreed thank you Ryan what do you
think of what robas just said I wanted
to stand up and clap I did
too I feel like I working for somebody
who can actually run a business when I
hear things like that that can succeed
I've never seen Robert so serious this
is actually really a life-changing thing
for him and I feel like I want to be
part of the changes thank you yes thank
you the truth is important it's humbling
to have to admit some of the things that
haven't gone right but at the same time
it's energizing to see that people
really do care for us and care for
Juniper Hill that is what's going to
make us
successful I'm impressed with the way
Robert dealt with his staff meeting I've
got real hope that he can make this
place work but he has another lesson to
learn he thinks people aren't spending
money at Juniper Hill because of the
recession but I think it's the snobbish
atmosphere and the high price that have
kept people away I'm taking Robert to a
fantastic local Brewery to show him how
a warm welcome can translate into money
in the bank let's go and have a beer
let's get in with the locals trust me
they won't beat you
up you are like a fish out of water
right now honestly you're like a
vegetarian in the middle of a big steak
tartar look at you no no well I love the
people from our region the Upper Valley
is filled with amazing people the
Juniper Hill is not with local people
wouldn't you welcome this atmosphere oh
oh yeah in your stately house absolutely
everyone is welcome stand on there and
tell them you need them hope we go if I
could have your attention please I'm
Robert I'm the inkeeper at Juniper Hill
in we just want to tell everybody we'd
love to have you all up at Juniper Hill
Inn and uh we need the help right now so
if you can come up and have dinner or
just have a drink and just say hi it
would be great thank you
excellent well done if Robert can always
be that inviting to the locals he surely
has it in him to be the leader of the in
when was the last time you brought AR
here for a beer we haven't been here
probably in 6 months how was he after
you spoke to the team like that you know
the the interesting thing with Ari is
his exterior is finish you know he's
very Stern Stern but he feels deeply he
can't express it though can he he can't
he's emotionally constipated I think he
gave up that can't come across to the
staff that can't come across to the
customer so you you got to almost
isolate yourself from that but he's
getting through it but he's not going to
be the face he's not going to be the ink
no he's not but he can provide a
phenomenal amount of support behind the
scenes cheers to
that coming up it's fantastic I show off
the new and improved Juniper Hill in oh
my goodness look at this but assistant
in keeper Sarah's Joy is shortlived I'll
be in my room you look terrible what's
the matter I'm sick of bit Gordon
[Music]
it's been a tough week here at Juniper
Hill in and owner Roberts pomper ways
have been maddening I don't have a
secretary Gordon I'm sorry are you
always this pathetic but he's finally
come off his pedestal to get on the same
level as his team you are all valuable
to Juniper Hill and we want to show you
that we are going to make a
difference overnight my team has been
working on a remarkable transformation
and with relaunch upon us it's a chance
for a fresh start for everyone good
morning good morning morning let me
introduce you to the new Juniper Hill in
it's no longer a hangout for the super
rich or your mates getting freebies yeah
it's now a nice warm and very welcoming
country in and trust me everyone is
welcome whether you're driving up here
in a Mercedes or even a pickup
truck you ready yes yes we are let's go
let's go let's go let's go let's go
please come in
come through the Great Hall is a
beautiful room but it was hidden by vast
amounts of furniture oh my goodness look
at this my team have edited the
collection and created a feeling of
comfort and space when I walked in at
the Great Hall it felt like a different
room Gordon put together this amazing
place it feels comfortable and warm you
have a spacious gracious warm reception
room look at it gone is That Hideous
makeshift bar thank gone
guests know where to go because they
have proper signs you ready to see the
dining room yes come
through it's warm and welcoming so
pretty oh I love this no longer feels
like your grandmother's parlor it really
is a dining room it's what do you expect
from country in you it has an identity
gone to those hideous sofas that nobody
can sit and eat dinner in Ari what do
you think very nice very nice you like
it very open excellent let show you my
bedroom okay please everybody else can
come too please
you ready we're ready in you
go do you know what's wrong with this
room
nothing you don't need to do anything to
them the only thing wrong was a smell in
room one and a plumber is taken care of
that the guest rooms are the absolute
highlight of your Inn that meant
something cuz it meant we were on the
right track we just needed uh uh better
directions now the key to filling this
is to charge sensible price
I would rather have the room sold at a
cheaper price and have an 85% occupancy
rate across the year the pric is down
fill it let them enjoy this quality the
stunning bedrooms didn't need changing
but there's one room that did need a
significant overhaul in order to bring
in much needed cash flow now there's one
more little thing I want to show you
downstairs okay you ready I'm ready
let's go come with
me okay we need to attract the local
community
I'd like to welcome you to the Blue
Bar Blue Bar God look at
this oh my
goodness Ari AR you thrilled the best
new local bar in Windsor fantastic this
is so czy walk in and see the people
sitting there and the games on the
tables and the Beautiful drinks it was
very emotional I loved it the blue bar
is exactly what the town of Winds of
amont and Juniper Hill Inn need I'm
hoping it will be popular especially on
a day like today when the Inn hosts its
first ever Sunday lunch service the
staff are all getting ready for the
arrival of their lunch guests 5 6 7 8 so
you got four tables each but while
everybody else is busy Ari seems lost
and needs reminding of his role here at
the in I'm here oh Jesus right okay to
go the other way are you in are you out
are you doing the checks what are you
doing I was checking in people you're
checking in but I thought that was the
great I thought you were checking people
you want to check them in and take them
up that'll be great would be so kind
just two seconds I'm so sorry would you
continue that I just have you for 30
seconds come I thought you were going to
leave the front of the house to Robert I
thought you going to be the back of the
house no one thing that Robert asked me
to to check in people uh because he had
to uh take people to the dining room
yeah I know but we have a saying in
England yes too many chefs spoil the
broth you're not a natural in
keeper oh okay okay he needs your help
but behind the scenes yes explain to
Robert that you're going to support him
from behind the scenes please sure
please I go do that I think Ari has
finally got the picture and understands
that he needs to play to his strengths I
really hope that things can continue to
improve
now come on Sophie we better remove the
dog she's going to eat the food Sophie
our poodle she shouldn't be in there I
mean it's a it's a place where we eat
come on Sophie come on come come come
de's not for you come on come on come on
come on honey excuse me come on come I
take care of the dog okay excuse me dog
shouldn't be in the bar he's on the
seats eating the food really I am the
boss okay don't ever talk to me that way
again excuse me don't ever and I mean it
I'll be in my room and I don't need to
be yelled
[Music]
at I'm coming towards the end of my stay
at Vermont Juniper Hill in and I thought
we'd turn the corner but as the in's
first ever Sunday lunch service
approaches assistant iner sah has gone
missing where's Sarah gone I haven't
seen Sarah in about a half an hour is
she okay I don't know you don't know
okay just asking has Sarah gone home
what has Sarah gone home I don't know
she know the team can't afford to be a
man down I've got to find
her who is it it's me Sarah's Gordon oh
hi Gordon are you okay oh no 's hold
dear dear D I thought you joining us for
lunch oh thanks I'm not going to what's
letter
you want to come here yeah you look
terrible what's the matter oh I'm just
really upset I don't want to get upset
you were with us half an hour ago
customers are in the bar I know my first
's just arrived I just expect you to be
there in terms of you're part of this
team I know but I I'm sick of being
yelled at by Ari I'm sick of it Gordon
when did he yell at you just a few
minutes ago because I asked him to take
the dog out of the dining room naturally
it's his dog and it's sitting on the bar
furniture please come back down oh [__]
up and come down nobody's ever seen me
break down in tears in the this in it's
never happened before just come back
downstairs okay please yeah I will okay
yeah I want to help I don't want to see
you upset and the girls need you down
there they do and I'm just I'm just
really mad at them no well let me go and
have a word with Ari this is ridiculous
get yourself ready place is full of
locals and they'd love to see you too
okay please H Smiley yes yes yes I'll
bounce back I'm not sure why Ari is
snapping at his star but it just proves
my gut was right about his place being
behind the scenes Ari yes I've just
found Sarah upstairs in floods of Tears
everything okay no we had a little run
in because we both are very strong
people she snapped at me and I snapped
back do you think the dogs should be
running around in the bar no no when
there are guests are coming so was she
right or wrong she was right would it be
appropriate for you to apologize to her
do do you feel that you're responsible
from behind the scenes is there any way
we could just for this first Sunday
lunch sure try to keep the team together
okay I think AR's heart is in the right
place but his tone is all wrong for an
inke keeper he needs to be the power
behind the
throne I'm sure this is going to be one
of the busiest days yet at Juniper Hill
Inn and I need to remind Chef Julian to
make good use of his Sue Chef needa if
he's going to have any chance of being
successful Junior's proved to Robert and
I that he has the talent and the
potential in the kitchen now he just
needs the help to execute I know you're
adant the fact that you're going to work
on your own but you are not a one-man
band yeah yes sure encourage
entice over to the stove the local
community have responded to Robert's
invitation and is a great atmosphere as
people turn up to check out the bar and
Sample the menu I put together with Chef
Julian Tara nice to see you welcome to
junifer Hill hi are you dear nice to see
you as well as new arrivals the in has a
returned guest hotel inspector Steve
talum his first visit was a disaster
very disappointed didn't meet
expectations from the moment I walked in
with no greeting I was totally lost this
is Robert and his team's chance to prove
to Steve that they've learned their
lesson I hope this time
Flawless how are you Mr Talon nice to
see you nice to see you welcome so this
is our new
menu okay what's going next coming up
next we have one Trout the key to this
place running smoothly is communication
among the entire staff but Chef Julian
still doesn't seem to get that how long
for the first flat iron please nether
medium rare medium R ask her Julian
medium
rare talk to Nether I don't care what
it's about the [__] weather I don't
care but talk to her
okay come on you got to
talk I just said come
on she can put things on a plate for you
just refusing to talk to her and it's
going be so [__] painful
now I simplified the menu in order to
get it so much easier for you know that
yes chef and the menu was designed for
you to open up and talk okay yes chef
look at me broaden your mind out and all
you do is one plate Focus next plate
focus and I just want you to open up a
little bit she's there to help thank
you you know what let me do
this just help with the Skillets help
with the skillet [__] hell Julian yes
come here [__] hell what's the matter
with you you just shut down on me now do
you want to give me your jacket I'll do
it for you no Chef it's not difficult I
know Chef can you do this open up come
on just shut
[Music]
down with Robert working well with the
team okay thank you so much and Ari
staying out the way the bar is bustling
how are you welcome what can I get you
the drink but Chef Junior needs to raise
his game and start communicating if
we're going to make today a success
you've just shut down on me open up
please get it together let's
[Music]
go you going be at 4 minutes of that
table so you do one plate I do one plate
is that good all right so then you get
with the lamb shank then you get some
lamb glaze which is right here Julian
nice much better look at me much better
yes yeah good how is everybody out there
chicken chicken wow the locals are
definitely noticing a change here was
wonderful it's very good I was very
surprised just was perfect me great time
to see if the hotel inspector has
two good to see you again good to see
you too recognize a few changes in some
ways I didn't recognize it at all so
good what the U entrance H in terms of
the total openness
welcoming signs everywhere when you
walked in was it warmth was there great
warmth now I feel it has that Diamond
collection feel a good job news enjoy
lunch appreciate porks amazing okay try
thank you there's a great Buzz at the in
Sarah can I have a second yes I hope
that's not all about to change I'm
really busy I just want to believe that
I'm sorry about what happened yeah I'm
sorry about that okay I mean I'm trying
to help AR you're you snarling me a lot
yeah I'm
sorry this food is affordably priced
it's really really tasty and it's nice
to know a nice place to send people to
get a drink and relax and everything and
that's hard in the area so that's great
Robert and I's communication has
improved by Leaps and Bounds since I've
been at the Inn let's go back in just
for a but actions speak louder than
words and I think Robert is starting to
understand that I just wanted to tell
you that um I really appreciate all the
extra effort you're given not just this
week but the entire time you've been
here and this is your paycheck it early
cuz we know you need it we wish we had
more we put $100 extra in there for you
just so you have a little bit extra
because we really do appreciate you Ryan
so thanks
you you and I are going to bring this
back and AR's going to join us
yeah I haven't been that emotionally
moved in a long time I I I feel like
it's all been worth it now I just I feel
like I it's
appreciated what a week I think this
business is on the road to recovery and
Robert Andy's team with ar in the
background can really make this place
work because once the locals invest in
this place word is going to spread Big
Time wow
beautiful it's time for me to say my
goodbyes but with the crowd enjoying
themselves in the bar and loving the
Great Value in the dining room it's a
hard place to leave really good this is
a nice compfy we're sharing the lamb
shakes the lamb okay thank you're
welcome uh right finally you seem to got
this under control yes yes chef and
you're opening up yes chef don't stop
talking yes chef communicates good job
thank you Chef he might have beat a few
people down but then he brought a few
people right back up and that was
necessary I'm just glad he didn't smack
me with a
spatula Ari chy I've come to take
goodbye I was uh doing my pay yourself
you're writing paychecks yes good luck
with the place it's a business
absolutely look after yourself look
after Robert and support him in all the
right places thank you best wishes we
are very grateful for him that he has
patient for
us cuz it it's not uh easy to
restructure molded Minds look out
yourself yes look after yourself right
how you feeling I'm feeling great and it
seems like you've got this under control
I'm going to keep it under control well
the staff doing the job the bar is
functioning the dining room's
functioning kitchen's functioning that's
good that's beautiful AR is in the RV
and there are people and they seem to be
having a good time you're on the track
now we're on track I got a little
present for you stay there having Gordon
come to Juniper Hill has meant a lot to
us it was harder than hell but
ultimately I know it's going to do great
things for our staff and for our town
this is something that money cannot buy
but this week you've earned it now the
most important thing please keep it up
this is your sign to be part of the
amazing setup the Diamond collection
thank you you deserve this thank you
well done thank you safe journey home he
really did awaken me put a fire in me
and I want him to come back and say you
really did it that's our goal take care
bye-bye a beautiful
day I can't believe those storage units
are still there
if I was Robert I'd lock Ari in one
[Music]
of tonight on Hotel Hell I'll be
investigating a murder mystery in the
Idaho town of C theane but the victim
isn't a
person it's the Roosevelt
in there are plenty of Clues as I dust
for fingerprints like someone's ashes in
an
an and
uncover horrific stains oh God brilliant
the prime suspect is the owner as
Sherlock Holmes wannabe who disguises
himself as a chef we must cook some
fabulous food but can't even boil an egg
oh it's
[Music]
wrong you're a [__] joke I'm going to
kill him just talk to my hand I've got
to solve the case before there's another
victim the owner's marriage I just feel
like I'm I'm going to
suffocate
[Music]
surrounded by stunning lakes and close
to two major ski resorts cord delain is
one of Idaho's Premier vacation
destinations it's also home to the
Roosevelt in the Inn is a 16 bedroom
converted Schoolhouse owned and run by
one of its former students John Hoff the
Roosevelt Inn is the first hotel I've
ever actually owned I was up here
signing the papers and I called my wife
Tina and I say we now own the Rosevelt T
and all of a sudden I hear
this because she started crying I did
not want to buy the hotel but John
really did I have told John many times
that he won't be cold in the ground and
I'm on my way home to Kentucky okay now
I'm not anymore to stop stop stop the
roosevel Inn is not just hell for Tina
it's hell for the guests who have to put
up with the consequences of John's
eccentric Behavior sorry we're not
trying to be a pain yes you are I would
say that the hotel is struggling because
it's dated it's old kind of smells funny
there the smells old probably because it
is old and the food coming out of the
Inn's shoe box size kitchen is as bad as
the
decor strong fish flavor oblivious to
the problems John's performance never
stops I'll ask you questions you'll give
me answers I'll ask questions you'll
give answers and I'll ask you questions
you'll give me answers as John's more
focused on playing dress up how was that
johon then I'm being an inkeeper John
refuses to grow old gracefully it's
Halloween for John every day he loves to
dress up it's the Cur it's the bloody
Cur once a month at the Roosevelt we put
on the murder mystery and dinner how's
everything going in here for you fine
okay I basically do everything uh you
want to finish making up this bed and
I'll do the bathroom okay great I feel
my dad doesn't appreciate my mom my mom
works three times harder than my dad
does there are times that I'll come in
and she's out busy doing something and
he's sitting on the couch reading a book
as the business has suffered so has John
and Tina's relationship we actually had
to go through marriage counseling at I
don't think John understands the
sacrifice I've made unless I can get
this place on the road to recovery John
and Tina will lose everything if I lose
the Roosevelt I don't just lose my job I
lose my home I become unemployed and
homeless and one F swoop dang it I don't
think we're going to pull out of this
[Music]
one I'm here in Kur delain Ido I
seriously hope this place is better than
the other [__] holes I've stayed in oh
my God
look at that they say all publicity is
good publicity but the billboard that
oldfashioned I'm not so sure you're
[__] joking aren't you come
on Roosevelt in bed and breakfast it's
like something out The Adams Family
Roosevelt School place looks Grim from
the
outside hello welcome to the Roosevelt
good to see you hi recognize that voice
you're Gordon Ramsey okay well good to
see my God look at those chairs there
are they from school they are those came
out of the first grade class classroom
well look you almost fit a reception for
dwarfs or
just first impression from the outside
it's almost like walking into a funeral
part
oh it smells like [__] as well what is
that is that the dog do a oh boy I sure
hope not oh Rohan jeez man Jesus this is
our dining room who's the chef here I
saw a billboard of a guy with the most
hideous hat on covered in trees and like
this Sixt hat
it's kind of grown into jeer Z mad
French chef the Roosevelt cuz you're in
cord is a French name town you know so
we must cook say fabulous food to Weare
this
outfit now you'll see um School photos
yes down the hallway here and these are
of kids that went to school here at the
Roosevelt and the ones with the arrows
pointing at the really cute adorable
little boy that's me of course because I
went to school here oh you went to
school my elementary school
who wants to live in their old school
it's like getting a detention That Never
Ends the guests get to hang out down
here with the dogs and watch TV you are
kidding
me you can't smell those dogs oh yes I
can the dogs actually believe it or not
Gordon are one of the highlights
here now you're sounding
deluded what's next our little Ballroom
or our multi-purpose room oh come on
Rohan you're not supposed to be in this
room don't you think this place to at
least had some form of makeover well
sadly Gordon we renovated this room four
years
ago this is new stop no this room looks
like it was last decorated in 1908 not
2008 and how much you spent on this
54,000 54,000
54 yeah not 5400 54,000 I know lovely
huh Christ amighty and is it generate
money no I can't believe anyone would
want to rent that space it's hideous I'm
dying to have a look upstairs it can't
get any worse it could get worse and
what's your uh occupancy across the year
probably around mid 20s 20% across the
board ouch I'm amazed you find it so
funny this is your
room okay what's with all the pink it's
like someone threw up strawberry
milkshake all over the place my room has
two levels each as bad as the other oh
everything looks like we're in a Time
War I mean it's so dated so my room how
much did you pay to stay in here uh 319
$319 bloody hell I'm
speechless 13-year-old Deco $39 a night
can I ask you something fire away why do
you think everything's a big
joke because you're very critical I'm
here to get this place right but what I
don't understand is how Blas you are to
the situation I'm going to give you the
truth and if you don't like that then
I'm out of it what do you want me to do
get angry and punch you you want to
punch me you go f well maybe I do want
to punch you a little bit but I can
become physically very very violent and
have in the past people get
hurt here's your
keys John John you can't just walk away
where you
[Music]
going since I checked into Idaho's
Roosevelt in I've been unimpressed by
the horrible Decor what's with all the
pain it's like someone's vomiting
everywhere and the dated event space
that smells like wet dog the dogs
actually are one of the highlights here
but the biggest problem here is the
owner John who seems to think it's funny
that he's in is a disgrace the only time
he stopped laughing was when I
confronted him with how bad things
really are here what I don't understand
is how Blas you are to the situation
here your
keys John you can't just walk
away while John hides on the truth
downstairs I'm going to have a close
look at my room it's like someone's
ashes in an AR an absolute
mess [__] that's what the rug's on the
floor for just gross at the dust on
there most disgusting of all [__] is the
dust magnet hanging over my
[Music]
pillows Jesus
how long's that thing been up there
help let me
out I hope I'll get a sense of what's
really going on here from John's wife
Tina Gordon this is my lovely wife how
are you I'm stressed out what hotel were
you running before this I was running a
dental office I worked in a dental
office I wasn't running anything except
my home so why would you go from sort of
teeth to a hotel because he bought a
hotel so you bought the hotel it was my
negotiation you negotiated you both
bought it yes willingly or unwillingly
unwillingly I was very happy and content
with the life that we had so when John
told me that we were buying the
Roosevelt I burst into tears how much
did you buy for 700,000 700,000 how much
you spend on it we owe 1,100,000 oh so
you haven't paid back the debt yet to
the bank owner yeah no the bank owns us
we sold our house we had here cashed in
a 401k everything we had oh my word that
where's your house now what you live in
we live in the building this is my hell
I have had terrible experiences here
business experience financial hardship
everything's just falling apart here for
me you seem serious you seem joking it's
almost like you're playing at it it is
kind of an entertainment though to a
certain degree at 1.1 million that's an
expensive entertainment well yeah I
didn't realize it was this bad how's the
relationship we're in a rough
place we went through marriage
counseling what was that four or 5 years
ago because of this business oh yeah and
still working together 7 days a week yes
24/7 in bed I'm ready for something to
change I'm ready for anything at this
point I just feel like
I'm I'm going to suffocate I'm going to
get my uh bag unpacked and I'll uh I'll
catch with you later thank you Tina
looks ready to bail out and all John can
do is laugh he thinks being over a
million dollars in debt is entertainment
I think this marriage is in as much
trouble as the in clearly in denial but
more
importantly a man that won't man up and
take
[Music]
responsibility I've been told that
tonight that Roosevelt Inn is holding a
murder mystery dinner it's an event they
host once a month I have a feeling it's
going to be hard to forget he if you
head on into there I'll get you all
checked in ready to go you look fabulous
we usually always have a lot of fun with
this we're going to continue to have fun
with this you addressing that for the
evening I play the part of Sherlock
Holmes old man you're playing an
Englishman I am playing an Englishman
and I even have the pipe to go with it
I've studied this accent long and hard
in fact mine is better than your British
accent I actually don't know where
Gordon got his accent he obviously
doesn't practice it very much mine is
far more authentic than his is
absolutely yes
wow while John pran is around as
Sherlock Holmes I wonder what US during
these events no oh my god what have you
got on this is crazy what happened to
you it's met a mystery night sir it's
gone from an in to Little House in the
prairie I mean honestly it'll be my job
this evening to cook your dinner so
while John gets to play Sherlock Holmes
his wife is stuck in the kitchen wake up
John this is not the 1800s anymore John
definitely like dressing up more for the
murder mysteries because he's not in the
hot kitchen he's out there haming it up
with the guests playing sh our it's
okay right um I'm not too sure what to
make of all this is a little bit bizarre
slightly weird I wonder if this event
even makes any money is this profitable
it is profitable yeah it's a lot of work
I mean we made $200 tonight $200 for all
this work and are they all staying over
oh no most of the locals you know when
they come from mster they usually don't
do an overnight clearly tonight is about
feeding John's ego not filling his bank
account oh well that that could explain
it then oh here now here now oh my word
I say oh my [__] god Here Come To Sir
ladies and gentlemen it appears the game
is a foot you know their goal with the
murder mysteries has always been to get
people in but if I'm not filling the
rooms what's the
[Music]
point and I would have G away with it
too if it wasn't for you and your
meddling guests I'll me your shl well
there you have it brilliant of all of
you
thank goodness that's over it's time to
find out from John what on Earth he
thinks he's doing sit down you must be
shattered I'm tired I bet you are stick
of fork in me that was mad was it mad
yeah you're in the kitchen busting your
ass off working hard to serve all those
people and John you were out prancing
around like a sort of actor this is the
thespian thing it's an inn it's not a
theater but you seem to enjoy it you
have to force yourself to like doing it
I mean it's on stage for 3 hours
[Music]
being the problems at the Roosevelt are
Elementary can I just have a word with
you on your own oh
sure this place is sinking because John
refuses to take anything seriously you
love being an Entertainer don't you dare
tell me that that is hard this whole
[__] thing was put together for your
fantasy well that's kind of what this
night is it is entertainment we put on a
show you're pretending to be Sherlock
Holmes and upstairs we're empty you're
in the [__] financially we're in Ruins
and if you put the same amount of effort
into filling this place just one room
book tonight would have made more profit
than the whole murder mystery and all
that work that went into it I mean this
is insane and you prance around like
some [__] idiot while your wife is
slaving away in the kitchen you any care
in the world apart for
yourself when you get a psychology
degree oh when I get you come and tell
me what's wrong with me here we go you
obviously think you are psychologist
denial again no I'm not in denial I just
don't know what you want it's only your
own [__] stupidity to why we're in
the [__] this far well that is probably
true so then man up and act
responsible okay I'm done with that oh
I'm done with that
in no is that that massage
no just talk to my hand you know talk to
my hand oh what a [__] idiot you're
not 10 years old you need to grow up and
stop running away from the
truth [__]
joke it was a rough first day and IAH
hose Roosevelt in let me out and last
night proved to me that owner John needs
to stop dressing up wait till I get
going and start growing up you prance
around like some [__] idiot and take
some responsibility for the problems at
the Inn it's only your own own [__]
stupidity to why we're in the [__] I'm
done with that but John didn't want to
listen just talk to my hand you know I
talk to my hand oh what a [__]
[Music]
idiot today I'm going to have another go
at getting through to him before he
heads into the kitchen to prepare lunch
you're losing money you're on this
treadmill of mistake after mistake we
may be in a elementary school but you're
not a child and I would really wish if
you you stop acting like one quickly is
that
possible sure show me what you got can
you get it I don't want to cook for
Gordon I mean first of all he's got a
huge ego of his own so you know nothing
anybody else does is going to be any
good I don't even want to cook him a
thing how are we doing over here word
are spread that I'm in town and the
dining room is full we're all having the
same five course set menu cooked in the
in Tiny Kitchen a shrimp cocktail to
start thank you that's gnarly that's
Gastly what the watery bits what's that
bit there um that's probably the tomato
juice unless it's condensation from the
shrimp condensation was it Frozen yes oh
[__] man warm that's a sad looking
shrimp that's not a good St it do really
taste okay I will take that for you and
everyone else seems to be hating it too
how can you [__] up a
sh okay here's Gordon pean crusted
salmon is it fresh salmon Frozen Frozen
that has to be the saddest looking plate
of salmon anywhere in North America
tonight the seasoning is D it's very dry
would you like me a tiet for you yes
please I'm sorry I'll take care of
you tastes great to me I'm going to kill
him I just want Gordon to take a long
walk off a short pier I want him to fall
into a very deep
pit so he can't get
out this is pathetic can Jon anything
can we cook an egg he can cook an egg
could you ask him just to boil me an egg
sure thing boow egg he can't possibly
mess up a softboiled egg can he
softboiled egg for G okay what
softboiled egg
what I'm just like
going
wow
no egg cup no I'll make my own egg cup
okay now was
[Music]
B oh it's raw is this really happening
he can't even boil a [__]
egg [__] thing still got feathers on
it could have probably cooked that
another 2
minutes I absolutely ready to boot
Gordon Ramsey out of my
end fire away buddy are you having a
laugh at your family's expense no big
tall hat big jacket and you can't boil a
[__] egg you want a fried
egg you want french toast too how about
some pancakes what the [__] are you
doing you don't care do you I do care
you're a [__]
joke those are what we refer to as
fighting words gutsy thing to do
especially in a kitchen full of sharp
knives it has never been a joke for me
ever come play at my school I'm the
Headmaster you're acting like an
absolute idiot no but you're in my house
that's right I'm disgusted at your
performance your big problem is you
can't handle the truth you don't like
hearing it you don't even know me you
know a joke think about your wife you're
in to$ 1.1 million of debt you're
forcing her to live in Hell she's
telling me that and just think of the
the last 13 years but what you've
[__] done and not to you to every
else standing behind you I'm tired of
hearing that I don't need it
anymore screw it I really don't care if
he leaves [__]
man I had a horrible night's sleep on
the couch because I couldn't sleep in my
bed I really need a hot shower
oh [__] [__] you know this water's
freezing I need to open John's eyes but
he walks out every time things get
difficult so I've got another plan have
you got 2 minutes we do there's
something I'd like to uh show you both
in my uh my room oh crap what now what's
wrong now please come through
[Music]
oh there's the jury and they're going to
hang us you recognize some of your
guests from the past 6 months we do I
think feedback is critical First
Impressions walking through the door a
lot of decorations it's kind of outdated
outdated yeah too much a lot going on at
once I'd like to go on to the food um
the general consensus how was it it was
it was too it wasn't the value that we
paid
honestly show of hands how many of you
would return and stay here again
please none of our guests would return
I'm kind of speechless I I'm I uh I
didn't expect this I thought it was I
thought we were better than that that's
the most valuable information you've had
in 13 years I thought we were a lot
better than this and that that is uh a
view that is changing you've got to put
yourself in the guest
position you know you've given me
feedback on everything you've seen and
experienced but there's something I'd
like to point out that none of you have
seen
please
would you be so kind to put a pair of
these on
please oh my gosh can this just get any
more terrible I don't think so glass
is's
on okay this black light is going to
show up any bodily
fluids let's start with the uh the
pillows shall
we it's there oh my God like someone
urinated on it absolutely
disgusting if you think that's
[Music]
bad this kind of stuff hasn't been weeks
that's that's
years oh oh absolutely hideous horrified
disgusted grossed out kind of want to go
vomit you kind of trust that things are
going to be you have the right to and
you have the this is just as bad as it
can possibly be I mean I'm disgusted
I how does that make you feel it makes
me actually feel sick to my stomach that
I slept on GL I took a shower but now
I'm wondering about the
shower I'll let you go thank you thank
you thank you all very much thank you
this is me I mean I've put my heart and
soul into this it's just so
embarrassing I had to do this because
you won't listen to me and John just
laughs at every problem I understand I
understand
now I'm worried about Tina hearing from
the guest and seeing those stains seem
to hit her pretty hard Tina yes have you
got two sex come on I'm not here to hurt
you I'm here to help you I'm just
banging my head against the wall with
John well I know what we do is not
perfect but I thought what we did was
better than that John's got to get out
of this
bubble he's an inkeeper but he's
constantly joking and shrugging
responsibility and now he has to start
looking at
himself the thing that bar probably
bothers me the most is John just refuses
to understand my need to have my part of
the dream I don't like living and eating
and breathing my work 24/7 and never
ever having a place to go that I can get
away
you're not happy
no I'm
[Music]
not at the end of the day I usually lay
down in the bed and I know this isn't
what I
wanted mhm and I'd leave here tomorrow
if I could leave here tomorrow I'm ready
just walk away from this and just forget
it want to leave want to get out of here
want to go away you can't give up 13
years of being unhappy it's not Mill
it's a mountain Do you have a voice
you've got to stand up you absolutely
have the right to be happy I mean that I
guess maybe I needed somebody to say you
have a right to be
happy so that was good thank
you I'll see you later okay I promise
you I'll make a difference and I mean
[Music]
that last night John's wife Tina was was
that a Breaking Point they not happy no
and I'd leave here tomorrow if I could
leave here tomorrow after talk to him I
realized how bad things really are here
and I promise to make things better
because Tina truly deserves to be happy
good morning Dy good morning how are
you I'm I'm here you're here um let's
catch up shall we let's get out of this
little cubby hole okay um maybe
downstairs I can't believe that John and
Tina have spent $60,000 on a ballroom
that they never use and smells like dog
looking at this in there's a a huge
missed opportunity the potential of this
room is extraordinary and this has to be
used as a way to get people into the
bedrooms upstairs and make money exactly
how often do you use this
room twice a month for that's crazy it
is have you ever thought about employing
a wedding planner to actually book this
place out I have one one I'm working
with been working with her for just
about a year now I don't pay her a
salary it's her wedding if we score a
wedding we both get paid so she's
motivated to sell it for me it's a big
missed opportunity yeah once you've held
an amazing wedding and you've got such
great feedback it just
spreads okay there's one I want to see
um I'll see you later yeah all right
thank
you this does not stack up I'm going to
go meet the wedding planet CU there must
be something that John and Tina aren't
telling
me hello how are you nice to meet
likewise where should we start well you
want to come on over and we'll have a
seat and yes come on
over the Ros of um what would you say
the key problems are it's dated it's um
it's hard to sell 10day old bread you
know brides are young they're
sophisticated they're on their phones
they're seeing what the rest of the
world is doing you know a big thing with
selling the ballroom is the colors that
only matches a tiny percentage you can
either go burgundy Ivory or navy blue
and those colors are so dated anyways D
it's terrible and then you walk
downstairs and the smell I had one girl
literally say I've got to go upstairs
the smell is going to make me sick John
doesn't strike me as someone that I'd
want to put my wedding in his hands as a
host how is he we have had some issues
um last summer with him coming out and
dancing at the guess wedding yes like
ballroom dancing or it was more like
marar type line dancing style oh my God
I mean how awward was that it was
mortifying
God if you just bear with me whilst I
make some changes because I mean you are
the key to their success going forward
would you give them one more
chance okay I'm in thank you good to see
you tooo good to see you thank you thank
you d
now that mist is on board to help the
Roosevelt I'm going to make one last
attempt to see if John is ready to
change how you
feeling I'm not here to hurt your
feelings John but you have a huge
defense mechanism I have an attitude I
want to help but you are a very tough
stubborn selfish individual to get
through to yeah Truth Hurts it's not a
sign of weakness to put your hand up and
ask for
help and I don't want to put heads I
don't want to but heads
either Gordon I've got two options here
I can close up the business walk away
from it give it to the bank the other
option is I know I've done this to
myself I've done this to my wife uh I've
got to find a way to get out of it this
has been your dream your ambition and
she just followed suit
you're correct you have one amazing
loyal lady that I don't deserve
her I'm a pig sometimes there's just no
doubt about it
you trying to change that she's not the
one that should be suffering because of
what I did and I haven't even considered
that in
yours let's start making this place
better I need you committed I want the
help I want to make this work
[Music]
coming up has John's change come too
late I've I've quit
[Music]
dreaming now that John's finally turned
the corner I'm a pig sometimes trying to
change that it's time to sit down with
Tina and get to the heart of their
relationship I'm so pleased that we've
got the place that we can start making
steps in the right direction this is a
family run in and you need need your
time out and you need to cut your dear
lady slack you need to learn The
Importance of Being a happy couple what
have you got to say now we've been so
wrapped up in this and everything we do
that we just don't even know where to
where to go with romance anymore it's
like I'm so
self-consumed with all of
this just the ability to just have a
conversation with you understanding my
my feelings I have wishes Ambitions
there are things
that are important to
me that are vitally important to me you
have to support that if you're not
prepared to support each other in each
other's roles then it's never ever going
to work you need to be happy together I
want to know what your dreams are
again I haven't heard a Dream from you
in years I don't even know what your
dreams are anymore I don't know what my
dreams are
anymore I've I've quit dreaming I want
you to start dreaming again and then I
want you to share those dreams with
me cuz I love you I know you do told all
my girls they were
princesses and you are too I haven't
treated you much like
royalty I do feel that Gordon has helped
John appreciate me more and see what's
going on inside of here
should matter to
him now that they're talking again I
want to give Tina John a lesson and
something else they've not done well for
a long time wow
cooking in any in Country Hotel it's all
about comfort and what I learn
immediately from you is that you're
trying way too hard you got a shoe box
of a kitchen that you can't swing a cat
in you shouldn't be cooking five course
meals in there okay you're not a Chef no
I'm not you shouldn't be on a billboard
I shouldn't be a delicious homecooked
meal that's all I'd expect to see that's
all i' expect to smell when you come
through that door so I've put together a
list of dishes for the whole week
something you can cook in one pot
fabulous let it cook itself really
fabulous these are my recipes I'm proud
of them don't start improvising changing
just follow them they will work half an
hour to get the chili on yeah fabulous
sweet nobody comes here John and Tin are
expecting a five course meal the food
was an amazing discovery that it could
be so simple so easy so delicious I'm
glad that Gordon is in my kitchen
tomorrow is a new dawn for the Rosevelt
and my goodness are we going to turn the
page my team worked all night to bring
the hotel into the 21st century now it's
time to reveal the new Roosevelt in good
morning good morning good morning G
you're springing your step John how you
feeling wonderful good let's go come in
come in come in please okay 16 rooms 32
guests this hotel should be full welcome
to your new honeymoon suite oh
wow look at Holy good John how do you
feel this is incredible Gordon a
honeymoon suite decluttered bright
elegant we were literally two centuries
back in time with what we were doing in
these rooms and we are suddenly into now
today it's amazing Jon Tina I'd like you
both to go
upstairs oh very pretty this is just
classy a room that will be great for
room service to have a bit of romance oh
this is just truly beautiful now coupled
with selling those rooms the big asset
that was underused in many ways was
downstairs truly that's been a huge
disappointment for me come with me now
and let me show you the new stunning
Roosevelt wedding
space I thought we had something that
would be viable to help build our
business and it wasn't it was dragging
it down oh good grief oh holy cow look
at this wo okay this is stunning this is
amazing absolutely amazing I love the
color scheme this is stunning oh my gosh
yes this is the direction we need to be
going in this is the next step up and I
am extremely grateful and I don't want
to see a dog wow a dog's hair a dog's
chew anywhere in this space understood
now this room should Propel this
business to Greater Heights it has to be
your biggest marketing tool because when
you got the wedding booked the guest
should book every room upstairs this
space and the revenue it can bring into
the Roosevelt could definitely be the
game Cher that we've been looking for
I'd like to um Point your attention to
those wonderful plates and all the glass
were on the
tables that's a special gift to you
where worth
$50,000 no way
really you've now got you know a solid
foundation to host the most amazing
wedding beautiful beautiful now there's
someone i' like you to meet one please
this is just you may recognize this
ladyy look at our new
space I hope Misty's going to give us a
second chance what strikes you now
walking through that room what's the
first thing that hits you it's just it's
it's natural it's it's modern it's what
the brides are looking for they're
sophisticated they're young this is what
they want and does it show sort of
Versatility in a way that it can be
adapted to suit different colors
absolutely we can put any color in this
room and it'll be wonderful yay this is
going to sell itself how does it smell
it smells
wonderful now here's the good news she
is prepared to give you one more chance
to become kurur land's number one venue
for hosting weddings one more surprise
John and Tina Miss's not just here to
visit the Roosevelt is hosting a wedding
tonight
[Music]
tonight owners of the Roosevelt Inn John
and Tina have come a long way from when
I first met them personally cuz I love
you and professionally I want to make
this work and I've just surprised them
with a true test for their business
the Roosevelt is hosting a wedding
tonight
wow tonight when Gordon said we had a
wedding tonight instant gut clenching
terror you're going to be cooking
serving just simple elegant food now
good
[Music]
luck are you my bride I'm the bride
hello welcome let me just take you
ladies up to the room all right go on in
ladies o like
that oh my dress guess are just starting
to arrive
hi I gave John and Tina a couple of
simple but delicious wedding recipes
that they could cook in their tiny
kitchen and that I knew the guests would
love this evening is going to be huge
for us you're feeling that that really
wound up sense inside yourself and it's
like holy
cow
Donald Nicole as the couple exchange
their vows downstairs upstairs in the
kitchen John and Tina are proving they
are there for each other when it matters
I give you all that I am I give you all
that I am and you may kiss your
bride you're that side on this side and
we go bang and then we go bang and then
so now plates in hands guys and
downstairs plates in hands serve it up
okay ladies let's go grab them and go
grab them and go for the first time ever
the food at the Roosevelt is putting a
smile on people's faces try and bunch
them up a little bit just make it look
so much neater including Tina breathe
and talk and okay I've got this awesome
we're in a nice rotation
here John and Tina are a great team when
they communicate
properly okay good and I think the buzz
they get from tonight will encourage
them to keep working on their
relationship how you doing we're right a
long ha got it I love it plates are
going away this the last the best thing
I've ever had well done okay how' you
feel where's John well done oh thank you
first time you've actually cooked yes
yeah from scratch from scratch for an
amazing wedding well done both you thank
you it's been a great night thanks to
John and Tina's teamwork you guys did it
even ahead of schedule you can do this
I'm really hoping that our future with
Misty and and our wedding business just
goes through the roof time to go I'm
going to be a bit sad to leave this
place I think John and Tina done a
bloody good job tonight and more
importantly I think the whole wedding
has opened their eyes the huge potential
they've got
here tonight the Roosevelt is fully
booked for the first time in years and
the Inn is back on course for Success
it's been a hell of a week yes at
tonight prove that you both can pull
this off once we got the system going I
it went very well stick together all
right we'll do it like Lou you've got
every chance now good luck you can have
a happy happy ever after let me tell you
thank you so
much take care of yourself thank you
again do not sneak downstairs to that D
Floor not even heading in that direction
n
[Music]
nights oh man hly so gorgeous oh my god
oh there's an upstairs thank you Gordon
Ramsey for giving us this opportunity
this experience obviously is not meant
to be easy but in the end worth it so
thank you very much it was nice to say
goodbye to him tonight and I look
forward to seeing him again
[Music]
actually